ne va pas parler de basket
rien ne
s'est passé avec notre équipe au cours des six dernières
heures
nous allons commencer de la même manière
ce soir
toutes les questions de basket n'ont pas d'importance
puisque nous avons laissé tourner environ 14 enfants
ont été tués à 400 miles d'ici
et un enseignant
et  au cours des 10 derniers jours, nous avons eu des
personnes noires âgées tuées dans un
supermarché à buffalo, nous avons eu des fidèles
asiatiques tués
dans le sud de la californie et maintenant nous avons des
enfants assassinés à l'école
quand allons-nous faire quelque chose
je suis fatigué je  Je suis tellement fatigué de me lever
ici et d'offrir mes condoléances aux
familles dévastées qui sont là-bas.
Je suis tellement fatigué de l'excuse. Je suis désolé, je suis
assez fatigué des moments de silence.
Il y a 50 sénateurs en
ce moment.  qui refusent de voter sur h.r 8,
qui est une règle de vérification des antécédents que
la maison a adoptée il y a quelques années,
elle est assise là depuis deux ans
et il y a une raison pour laquelle ils ne voteront
pas pour conserver le pouvoir,
alors je vous demande mitch mcconnell  je vous demande à
tous sena  tors qui refusent de faire
quoi que ce soit à propos de la violence dans les fusillades dans les écoles
et les fusillades dans les supermarchés, je
vous demande si
vous allez faire passer votre propre
désir de pouvoir avant la vie
de nos enfants, de nos personnes âgées et de
nos fidèles
parce que c'est à quoi ça ressemble
c'est ce  nous faisons chaque semaine
donc
j'en ai marre j'en ai assez
nous allons jouer au jeu ce soir
mais je veux que chaque personne ici chaque
personne qui écoute ceci pense à
votre propre enfant ou petit-enfant ou mère
ou père ou soeur frère  comment
vous sentiriez-vous si cela vous arrivait aujourd'hui,
nous ne pouvons pas nous engourdir, nous ne pouvons pas nous asseoir
ici et simplement lire à ce sujet et allons-y,
prenons un moment de silence
nous allons faire nous
allons jouer à un match de basket
et 50 sénateurs à Washington vont
nous prendre en otage
vous rendez-vous compte que 90% des
américains,
quel que soit le parti politique, veulent
une vérification des antécédents vérification universelle des antécédents
90 d'entre nous nous sommes lui  ld otage
par 50 sénateurs
à washington qui refusent même de le mettre
aux voix malgré
ce que nous, le peuple américain, voulons
qu'ils ne votent pas parce qu'ils
veulent conserver leur propre pouvoir
c'est pathétique j'en ai assez